je vous emmène aujourd'hui chez Honor
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va venir voir chez
Honor aujourd'hui alors regardez ça va
être super cool on va parler de
smartphone qui se plie au nord vous
savez c'est le grand retour depuis un an
et demi de la marque c'était avant la
marque jeune de Huawei sauf que ils sont
séparés de Huawei c'est une vieille
histoire et la marque serait un ventes
et surtout la marque qu'elle vient faire
et c'est super intéressant c'est pour ça
que ça nous intéresse et bien elle vient
monter en gamme avec des produits
extrêmement premium on a vu cette année
le Magic 4 pro qui a un super produit
qui est très très cool il y a le Honor
70 qui a le milieu de gamme qui succès
de Honor 50 qui est cool qui va bien et
là il vient de montrer pour la première
fois un smartphone pliable qui s'annonce
en tout cas être extrêmement fin
extrêmement cool donc l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est de venir voir devenir le découvrir
de venir voir ce qui propose si il est
réellement intéressant et voir en fait
la premiumisation de Honor même si a
priori ce produit sortira en France mais
pas tout de suite devrait sortir
potentiellement l'année prochaine on
sait pas réellement quand donc on vient
voir tout de suite là avec des
journalistes la conférence qui elle est
diffusée en Chine et puis surtout prise
en main du produit donc bougez pas on va
regarder ça on va les courir on va voir
si ce nouveau smartphone s'appelle le
Magic V on va voir s'il est cool tout
simplement allez
regardez ce que j'ai là nouveau
smartphone qui part encore sorti quand
on va pas savoir si il va sortir tout de
suite en tout cas il va sortir
probablement l'année prochaine c'est au
nord c'est le Magic vs alors ils ont
présenté deux smartphones on a le Magic
vs et il y a le Magic VNI enfin bref
j'ai pas vraiment le nom la grosse
différence ça va être l'arabe ça va être
le stockage et surtout sur l'autre
modèle on a un stylet qu'on va pouvoir
venir ranger avec les tuiles est-ce
qu'on a besoin d'un stylet est-ce qu'on
veut un stylet peut-être pour un usage
professionnel ça reste très nicher un
smartphone qui est plutôt sympa à voir à
quel prix il va arriver c'est vraiment
ce qui va le rendre attrayant et
intéressant par rapport à ce qu'on a sur
le marché aujourd'hui très clairement
aujourd'hui en France si on veut acheter
un smartphone qui se plie notamment 60
facteurs là on va chez qui on va chez
Samsung maintenant on va voir comment
est-ce que les choses vont venir bouger
l'année prochaine en 2023 parce que ce
qui est très clair c'est que on voit
qu'il y a des acteurs très forts avec de
gros moyens notamment au nord ici qui a
peu le dignité de Huawei qui arrive avec
un truc qui est très sexy qui est très
cool je vous montrer aussi l'autre jour
le mix fold 2 de Xiaomi même si pour
l'instant il n'est pas encore annoncé
comme sortant en France mais bon je
pense que ça finira par arriver le
marché reste très niché aujourd'hui le
format qui marche c'est le flip de
Samsung c'est le smartphone vous allez
réduire l'encombrement c'est très
clairement le truc qui se vend par
palette je pense ça ça reste plus nicher
mais ça montre et je pense que c'est
vraiment le truc qui est intéressant ici
pour Honor France ça montre la capacité
d'innovation ça consolide l'image de
marque ça montre ce qu'ils ont sous le
capot ils sont capables de vous proposer
voilà donc même si il est clair que ce
smartphone là ils vont pas en vendre des
sauts quand ils sortira en France
continue à jouer leur crédibilité dessus
et à montrer que ils sont très sérieux
et que dans le très haut de gamme on
peut venir compter aujourd'hui en 2022
et en 2023 surtout encore plus sur Honor
alors je suis Sam et je bosse pour phone
Android alors dis-moi tu en penses quoi
toi de ce Magic vs franchement ça a
l'air d'être pas mal du tout un produit
qui est quand même très qualitatif très
jolie avec une belle texture à l'arrière
franchement c'est très sympa et puis
vraiment très bel écran à l'intérieur ça
c'est canon tu penses que ça va
smartphone qui pourrait marcher qui va
se vendre ça ou pas une question c'est
une bonne question alors parmi ceux qui
sont des férus de marques chinoises et
qui aiment vraiment la haute technologie
pourquoi pas il y a vivo qui est déjà
sur ce marché là il y a aussi Xiaomi il
y a aussi pas mal de monde etc là ça va
être vraiment la première marque
finalement chinoise qui va être lancée
en France et ça ça va être vachement
bien pour une fois il va y avoir
vraiment une innovation chinoise qui va
arriver en France et ça assez rare donc
rien que pour ça déjà c'est pas mal
est-ce que ça va se vendre je suis pas
sûr encore ouais ça reste vraiment un
truc très nicher quoi ouais ça sera
niche et puis en plus au nord qu'on
connaît pas vraiment beaucoup enfin si
on connaît mais il faut réapprendre à
connaître parce qu'ils sont été absents
pendant quand même pas mal de temps donc
c'est vrai que sur le très haut de gamme
on les connaissait pas beaucoup là bon
c'est quand même un produit qui va être
vendu 1500 balles à peu près on sait pas
vraiment quoi mais bon on sait pas
encore potentiellement on pense que ça
veut dire que bon si on fait la
conversion avec le prix chinois on voit
tout de suite que ça arrive vers 1500 €
quoi ok on va faire à suivre quoi
exactement
alors voilà la bête alors regardez déjà
en termes de design moi il fait
vachement penser au smartphone que je
vous ai montré l'autre jour de Xiaomi
c'est-à-dire légèrement un curvé sur le
côté ici voyez au niveau de l'écran donc
ça fait un très très grand écran et ça
c'est vachement cool parce que c'est
hyper confort lorsqu'on veut venir
regarder visionner c'est beaucoup mieux
que ce que propose Samsung aujourd'hui
sur le Galaxy Z fold 4 mais ça fait
vraiment pensé à la copie de Xiaomi le
truc que j'ai tout de suite remarqué ça
vous allez voir c'est un peu arbitre
c'est à dire qu'en fait lorsque vous
l'ouvrez tout de suite résistance et dès
que ça s'ouvre ça devient un peu plus
lâche et en fait il y a pas de système
de crantage il y a pas comme chez
Samsung flexbox c'est-à-dire qu'on peut
pas normalement le laisser comme ça il
est soit ouvert soit fermé c'est ce que
nous dit Honor ici vous voyez que je
viens le reposer il tient pas la
position donc je pense que c'est
vraiment un truc qui est fait pour être
soit ouvert soit fermé quand vous
l'ouvrez à la différence du smartphone
de Xiaomi c'est que vous avez une caméra
de selfie à l'intérieur je peux chez
Samsung on retrouve avec une caméra qui
est planqué sous l'écran depuis le Z
fold 3 donc bon ça me dérange pas je
pense que la techno de la caméra sur
l'écran Aujourd'hui c'est Samsung qui là
et que les autres font pas
nécessairement en tout cas s'ils l'ont
ils sont en train de travailler dessus
c'est vraiment pas finalisé après on a
un très grand écran et en terme de de
prise en main en terme de confort c'est
cool autre point sur la pliure on la
sent sous le doigt mais c'est pas
surprendra plus pas moins que ce que
j'ai vu sur le mix fold 2 de Xiaomi ou
un peu moins que chez Samsung et puis
surtout c'est une charnière goutte d'eau
regardez hop là on voit rien à travers
ça va totalement le plier donc ça c'est
pas mal fichu sinon les finitions je les
aime bien je trouve très premium
franchement très sympa un petit dos mat
team module photo qui est un peu
différent aussi vous voyez parce qu'il a
une espèce de forme là on est arrondie
arrondi et là on est en forme de pointe
donc un truc qui est assez marrant qui
est assez bien vu très esthétique assez
joli là-dessus je trouve que Honor a
bien bossé le produit est cool
franchement
à manipuler maintenant il y a cette
petite charnière je sais pas voyez je
reste un petit peu un peu dubitatif je
sais pas ce que ça va raconter plus tard
ça ça fera vraiment avoir quand ce
produit sortira en tout cas en en France
qui est pas le cas tout de suite il
reste un point d'interrogation il nous
dit après c'est vraiment des symptômes
donc c'est pas du tout un produit qui
est fini et qui va être commercialisant
les tâches parce que encore des
modifications quand il arrive en France
les petits bords légèrement arrondis sur
le côté et voilà donc sinon écoutez moi
je trouve je trouve pas mal ça va
vraiment dépendre du prix une fois de
plus et ce que nous propose là-dessus au
nord celui qui sont balancé plein de
techno il y a plein de choses alors une
fois de plus faudra voir ce qui arrivera
en France parce qu'il se peut qu'il y a
vraiment une différence entre ce qui va
arriver en France et ce qu'on a ici en
tout cas sous la main mais bon sur le
principe le produit est assez rigolo les
hauts du café du Geek ça va ouais ça va
tu me prends le coup je te prends le
cours alors toi tu viens tout juste de
le prendre en main première sensation à
chaud tu en penses quoi j'aime bien
claque comme ça se ferme
tu vois donc vraiment
très beau magnifique l'écran prise en
main très agréable attends comment on
déverrouille il y a peut-être un couteau
je vois que des points positifs pour
l'instant pour l'instant tu es plutôt
smartphone il est cool il est
intéressant je le prends main je trouve
joli gagne rien de trois points que je
voulais voir avec vous au côté de la
fiche technique alors l'idée c'est pas
de vous faire une lecture fiche
technique parce que ça on s'en fout
complètement mais il y a des trucs qui
sont intéressants également dans la
fiche technique et qui nous permettent
de comprendre un peu plus ce que vient
raconter ce Honor Magic vs alors
regardez je vous le dis déjà et en plus
de ça alors je sais pas si vous avez vu
mais l'autre jour je vous ai fait une
vidéo pour vous parler de ce smartphone
pour vous parler de celui-là c'est le
Xiaomi c'est le mix fold 2 où je me le
mettais en face du Z fold de 4 de
Samsung et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'en fait ce sont des très grandes
marques et c'est très grandes marques
elles viennent montrer ce qu'elles sont
capables de faire alors pour l'instant
le smartphone pliable de Xiaomi n'est
pas prévu d'arriver en France contrario
de celui de Honor qui va arriver mais
c'est quand même cool de venir regarder
un peu fiche technique par fiche
technique voir un peu ce qui vient de
faire alors regardez déjà au niveau de
la taille des écrans ce smartphone de
Honor le Magic vs est un écran intérieur
de 7,9 pouces c'est une dalle OLED avec
un taux de rafraîchissement qui va
jusqu'à 90 Hertz on dirait c'est tout
381 pixels par pousse OK et alors écran
extérieur on est sur du 6 45 pixels là
c'est du 120 Hertz c'est de l'aide
également alors ça se tient un peu avec
celui de Xiaomi Xiaomi en intérieur on
est à 8,2 7,9 vrai bon c'est kif kiffe
et à l'extérieur on est sur du 6,5 pour
Xiaomi 6,4 donc vous voyez c'est
vraiment vraiment quasiment la même
chose le truc qui vachement intéressant
c'est qu'en fait ce que nous présente au
nord ici c'est un smartphone qui va
sortir je vous dis s'il est présenté en
France à l'horizon février 2023 on n'est
pas mal on tient le truc sauf qu'il nous
disent ok le processeur qui aujourd'hui
est présenté à l'intérieur c'est le
stade dragon 8 plus Jane 1 qui est
aujourd'hui en tout cas le processeur le
plus puissant qui existe sur le marché
sauf que va arriver a été présenté je
vous ai emmené l'autre jour à Hawaii
pour vous le montrer 8 gène 2 la
nouvelle génération qui est plus
puissant qui est boostée à
l'intelligence artificielle d'ailleurs
allez voir ma vidéo si vous ne l'avez
pas vu comme ça vous allez vraiment
savoir ce qui va arriver l'année
prochaine dans 2023 je trouverai ça
logique sur un smartphone pliant pliable
comme on veut qui sera très haut de
gamme à des tarifs assez élevés on est
le processeur le plus puissant du moment
alors est-ce que il va être équipé de la
nouvelle puce de Qualcom allez savoir
toi ça me paraît très bien donc de toute
façon on en reparlera de ça l'année
prochaine donc venez vous abonner si
c'est pas déjà fait bon grosse batterie
de 5000 milliards la charge rapide 66
watts ok ça me paraît logique je vous
passe un peu le truc au niveau de la
photo un triptyque très très classique
qu'on retrouve un grand angle de 54
mégapixels un ultra grand angle de 50
mégapixels et intérêt d'objectif suivez
les gars pixel je ne t'ai pas parlé toi
et lui mégapixel avec un zoom optique x
3 bon ok voilà le truc est vraiment
intéressant pour moi c'est savoir la
taille des écrans c'est de voir le
processeur qu'il mette à l'intérieur et
de voir qu'en fait ce que propose au
nord est-ce que montre au nord qui va
arriver sur le marché ils le disent et
bien c'est assez semblable même s'il y a
quelques points de différence à la copie
de Xiaomi le mix fold 2 qui par contre
tous les deux sont quand même assez
différents du Galaxy Z fold 4 de Samsung
parce que bon les choix sont un peu pas
tu as fait les mêmes maintenant est-ce
que Samsung va venir modifier sa copie
en 2023 pour correspondre à ce qui
potentiellement pourrait des standards
c'est-à-dire notamment d'avoir un écran
plus grand à la face avant ça jusqu'au
présent c'est quand même un truc qui
quand on voit les autres et bah c'est
pas ouf sur le Samsung parce que c'est
vrai que autant ce qu'on voit sur Honor
est-ce qu'on voit chez Xiaomi on a des
très très grandes dalles et c'est
vachement plaisant tandis que
aujourd'hui et bien chez Samsung c'est
quand même mieux qu'avant mais voyez il
y a encore un peu de temps donc on
regardera ça et ça c'est chouette
ça va Georges salut à toi Aurélien ouais
donc toi tu bosses au nord question
toute simple c'est quoi la volonté de
Honor avec ce smartphone parce que au
nord vous vous arrivez effectivement
vous étiez avant avec Huawei ça c'était
une vieille histoire vous avez
aujourd'hui indépendant vous êtes arrivé
avec des smartphones trio de gamme
notamment le Magic 4V il y a aussi
l'audience 70 qui est très cool dans le
milieu de gamme milieu haut de gamme et
là on arrive quand même avec un autre
produit ça raconte une nouvelle histoire
même si c'est pas le premier smartphone
pliant chez vous pourquoi venir faire un
focus aujourd'hui sur un smartphone qui
vient se plier alors que ça reste quand
même des choses qui se vendent pas
énormément on le voit à la concurrence
c'est quoi l'envie de Honor là-dessus
aujourd'hui comme tu disais
effectivement on est à la fois une
entreprise qui est neuve et une
entreprise qui est ancienne puisque on
existe depuis 2013 mais le nouveau Honor
existe seulement depuis deux ans on
avait un public auparavant qui était un
public très défini qui était des jeunes
qui voulaient la technologie à un prix
relativement abordable et aujourd'hui
maintenant que tout ça va indépendant
nous avons la capacité comme tu l'as
souligné aussi de monter en gamme avec
notamment l'arrivée par exemple du Magic
4 pro cette année le Magic vs que tu
vois ici effectivement la deuxième
version de nos smartphones c'est un
produit qui de montrer toutes les
tendues aujourd'hui de la R&D des
capacités de Honor de la marque Honor
sur le haut de gamme et sur la partie
enfin sur la téléphonie de manière
générale l'idée c'est qu'aujourd'hui nos
clients et nos consommateurs en voyant
ce qu'on est capable de faire sont
capables aussi de se dire que nous
sommes une entreprise sur laquelle il
faut compter et sur lesquels bien sûr on
est capable aujourd'hui de fournir des
technologies qui sont des technologies
novatrices et les dernières technologies
de manière générale sur l'ensemble de
nos produits bien sûr c'est une façon de
rassurer consommateur en fait de dire
parce que très honnêtement aujourd'hui
un smartphone comme celui-là même si il
a plein de techno même si il est hyper
canon c'est pas forcément ce que les
gens vont acheter le plus c'est un
produit aussi qui va être relativement
cher est-ce que c'est pas un peu pour
aussi crédibiliser et rassurer le
consommateur là-dessus
je pense qu'on est plus sur une idée de
crédibilisation de la marque bien sûr ça
rassure le consommateur de voir qu'on
est capable de le faire mais c'est un
profond comme ça c'est la capacité qui a
aujourd'hui au nord de se positionner
sur tous les marchés de la téléphonie de
l'entrée de gamme jusqu'au très haut de
gamme en passant par toutes les
technologies récentes qui ont été
apportées sur ce marché par d'autres
marques
comment tu fais comment tu fais avec
comment je fais quoi
bien sûr donc conducteur
donc voici le Magic vs de chez Honor et
il est vachement bien ce téléphone il
arrivera en 2023
bon je te laisse bosser
premier semestre 2023 d'accord ok
[Rires]
c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous
raconter aujourd'hui sur ce Honor Magic
vs je trouve ça intéressant alors
attendez calmons-nous calmons-nous
qu'allons-nous pourquoi et bien parce
que tout simplement se forme factor là
vous savez l'idée d'avoir c'est pas
celui-là ça c'est celui de Xiaomi mais
d'abord un grand écran comme ça et puis
quelque chose avec une taille de
smartphone un peu plus classique c'est
pas ce qu'ils ont eu lieu aujourd'hui
acheter Samsung parce qu'aujourd'hui
Samsung et le seul à vendre des
smartphones qui se plient même s'il y en
a d'autres qui le propose c'est Samsung
aujourd'hui qui est la seule marque à
les vendre donc on verra si au nord
réussite Paris de les vendre au-delà de
faire le travail pour continuer à
crédibiliser et à soi la marque donc on
va drasser l'année prochaine en 2023
alors d'ici 2023 il va se passer plein
de choses donc bien évidemment rester
connecté continuez à vous abonner restez
abonnés abonnez-vous activez la cloche
c'est pas déjà fait et puis surtout
dites-moi ce que vous vous pensez de ce
nouveau smartphone qui est annoncé de
Honor vous me le dites juste en bas dans
les commentaires puis nous on se
retrouve très bientôt bien évidemment
pour continuer à parler de l'amour